the human voice it's the instrument we
all play
it's the most powerful sound in the
world probably it's the only one that
can start a war
or say i love you and yet many people
have the experience that when they speak
people don't listen to them why is that
how can we speak powerfully
to make change in the world what i'd
like to suggest there are a number of
habits that we need to move away from
i've
assembled for your pleasure here seven
deadly sins of speaking
i'm not pretending this is an exhaustive
list but
these seven i think are pretty large
habits that we can all fall into
first gossip speaking ill of somebody
who's not present
not a nice habit and we know perfectly
well the person gossiping
five minutes later will be gossiping
about us
second judging we know people who are
like this in conversation and it's very
hard to listen to somebody
if you know that you're being judged and
found wanting
at the same time third negativity
you can fall into this my mother in the
last years of her life became very very
negative and it's hard to listen i
remember one day i said to her
it's october the first today and she
said i know isn't it dreadful
it's hard to listen when somebody's that
negative
and another form of negativity
complaining well this is the national
art of the uk it's it's our national
sport we complain about the weather
about sport about politics about
everything
but actually complaining is viral misery
it's not spreading sunshine and
lightness in the world
excuses we've all met this guy maybe
we've all been this guy some people have
a blame thrower
they just pass it on to everybody else
and don't take responsibility for their
actions and again hard to listen to
somebody who's being like that
penultimate the six of the seven
embroidery
exaggeration it demeans our language
actually sometimes
for example if i see something that
really is awesome
what do i call it
and then of course this exaggeration
becomes lying out and out lying and we
don't want to listen to people we know
are lying to us
and finally dogmatism
the confusion of facts with opinions
when those two things get conflated
you're listening into the wind you know
somebody is bombarding you with their
opinions as if they were true
it's difficult to listen to that so here
they are
seven deadly sins of speaking these are
things i think we need to avoid
but is there a positive way to think
about this yes there is
i'd like to suggest that there are four
really powerful
cornerstones foundations that we can
stand on
if we want our speech to be powerful and
to make change in the world
fortunately these things spell a word
the word is hail and it has a great
definition
as well i'm not talking about the stuff
that falls from the sky and hits you on
the head
i'm talking about this definition to
greet or acclaim
enthusiastically which is i think how
our words will be received
if we stand on these four things so what
do they stand for
see if you can guess the h honesty
of course being true in what you say
being straight and clear
the a is authenticity just being
yourself
a friend of mine described it as
standing in your own truth which i think
is a lovely way to put it
the i is integrity being your word
actually doing what you say
and being somebody people can trust and
the l
is love i don't mean romantic love
but i do mean wishing people well for
two reasons first of all i think
absolute honesty may not be what we want
i mean my goodness you look ugly this
morning
perhaps that's not necessary
tempered with love of course honesty is
a great thing
but also if you're really wishing
somebody well
it's very hard to judge them at the same
time i'm not even sure you can do those
two things
simultaneously so hail
also now that's what you say and it's
like the old song it is what you say
it's also the way that you say it
you have an amazing toolbox this
instrument is incredible
and yet this is a toolbox that very few
people have ever opened
i'd like to have a little rummage in
there with you now and just pull a few
tools out that you might like to take
away and play with
which will increase the power of your
speaking register for example
now falsetto register may not be very
useful most of the time
but there's a register in between i'm
not going to get very technical about
this for any of you who are voice
coaches
you can locate your voice however so if
i talk up here in my nose you can hear
the difference if i go down here in my
throat which is where
most of us speak from most of the time
but
if you want weight you need to go down
here to the chest
you hear the difference we vote for
politicians
with lower voices it's true because we
associate
depth with power and with authority
that's register and we have tamba it's
the
the way your voice feels again the
research shows that we prefer voices
which are rich
smooth warm like hot chocolate
well if that's not you that's not the
end of the world
because you can train go get a voice
coach and there are amazing things you
can do with breathing with posture
and with exercises to improve the timbre
of your voice
then prozody i love prozadie this is the
sing-song the meta language
that we use in order to impart meaning
it's root one for meaning
in conversation people who speak all on
one note
are really quite hard to listen to if
they don't have any prosody at all
that's where the word monotonic comes
from or monotonous
monotone also we have repetitive
president now coming in
where every sentence ends as if it were
a question when it's actually not a
question it's a statement
and if you repeat that one over and over
it's actually restricting your ability
to communicate through prosidy which i
think is a shame
so let's try and break that habit
pace i can get very very excited by
saying something really really quickly
or i can slow right down to emphasize
and at the end of that of course is our
old friend silence
there's nothing wrong with a bit of
silence in a talk is there
we don't have to fill it with um's and
ours
can be very powerful of course pitch
often goes along with pace to indicate
arousal but you can do it just with
pitch
where did you leave my keys where did
you leave my keys
it's a slightly different meaning in
those two deliveries
and finally volume i can get really
excited
by reusing volume sorry about that if i
startled anybody
or i can have you really pay attention
by getting very quiet
some people broadcast the whole time try
not to do that
that's called sod casting
imposing your sound on people around you
carelessly
and inconsiderately not nice of course
where this all comes into play most of
all is when you've got something really
important to do it might be standing on
a stage like this and giving a talk to
people
it might be proposing marriage asking
for a raise
a wedding speech whatever it is if it's
really important you owe it to yourself
to look at this toolbox and the engine
that it's going to work on and no engine
works well without being warmed up
warm up your voice actually let me show
you how to do that would you all like to
stand up
for a moment i'm going to show you the
six vocal warm-up exercises
that i do before every talk i ever do
anytime you're going to talk to anybody
important do these first arms up
deep breath in and and sigh out
like that one more time
very good now we're going to warm up our
lips and we're going to go
very good and now
just like when you were a kid now your
lips should be coming alive
we're going to do the tongue next with
exaggerated
beautiful you're getting really good at
this and then rolling our
that's like champagne for the tongue
finally and if i can only do one
the pros call this the siren it's really
good it starts with we
and goes to all the wii is high the
always low so we go
fantastic give yourselves a round of
applause take a seat thank you
next time you speak do those in advance
now let me just put this in context to
close
this is a serious point here this is
where we are now right we speak not very
well
into people who simply aren't listening
in an environment that's all about noise
and bad acoustics i have
talked about that on this stage in
different phases
what would the world be like if we were
speaking powerfully
to people who were listening consciously
in environments which were actually
fit for purpose or to make that a bit
larger
what would the world be like if we were
creating sound consciously
and consuming sound consciously and
designing all our environments
consciously for sound that would be a
world that does sound beautiful
and one where understanding would be the
norm
and that is an idea worth spreading
thank you
[Applause]